first up on behalf of America I think we
owe France an apology a pair of drunk us
tourists pulling an all-nighter in the
Eiffel Tower after jumping the security
barriers and getting trapped security
guards stumbled upon the Tipsy
Daredevils early in the morning the next
day and now they face possible legal
consequences no
no
[Music]
America does not have to apologize to
France for anything for a long time for
many many decades America does not have
to do that France should be thanking us
that you're welcome that we come and
visit you I'm sorry about the Eiffel
Tower thing but the whole recipe like
the other things you know one and two
but it's kind of funny like they're all
these like Museum heist movies where
Americans go and steal like the Pink
Panther Jewel and then now we're just
going over there and like getting drunk
like sorry Sweeping in their monuments
yeah
Greg have you ever slept in the Eiffel
Tower uh I've done some things there can
you imagine how tall the Eiffel Tower is
compared to me it's very tall but I'm I
find that it's probably the most
overrated uh uh monument in on the
planet
um anybody could put that together it's
uh it's basically like a child's Erector
Set remember those yeah yeah you get
there and you're like that's all there
is can we agree there's nothing more
annoying than drunk tourists unless you
are
it's the best out of your life you know
today driving up at the on Sixth Avenue
looking at terrorists and going like
what can what do you see yeah why did
you come here to look at the building I
mean it's awful I just see ugliness
everywhere and it would and then but
there's all these families here so
apparently your ugliness is another
person's Splendor or beauty is in the
eye of the behold I don't think they're
coming up to see you how dare you
um favorite City to be drunken
um when you're visiting
long long time but
um I just think it's amazing and we've
got the Coliseum the Trevi Fountain yeah
and now the Eiffel Tower I mean people
just go to Europe and go crazy they have
a good time I think they just feel like
I love it here
um I went to Malta and belletta just
blew my mind if I were going to do that
I was just gonna say if you want to get
drunk and see the Eiffel Tower just go
to Blackpool England they have a replica
yes
anything okay everyone to Vegas hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else